und noch eine bluttat nach dieser
sowieso schon so blutigen woche passiert
gerade eben in hamm in nordrhein
westfalen an der dortigen hochschule
da ist ein mann mit einem messer
rumgelaufen rat offenbar mehrere
menschen mit diesem messer verletzt das
hat die polizei jetzt gerade erst
bekannt gegeben über twitter unser
reporter ist dort sebastian prengel und
kann uns erste informationen dort vom
tatort geben sebastian live zu dir nach
hamm was wissen wir über diese tatort an
der hochschule
jacke hier hatte am späten nachmittag
ein 34 jähriger mann in einem
seminarraum mehrere studenten mit einem
messer attackiert wird sich nach unserem
kenntnisstand gibt es vier verletzte
drei frauen und ein mann eine der frauen
ist so schwer verletzt worden dass sie
mit einem rettungshubschrauber in die
klinik gebracht werden musste und nach
der tat ist der täter von studenten
überwältigt worden und festgehalten
worden bis die polizei eingetroffen ist
was wir jetzt hier im hintergrund sehen
ist folgendes das sek ist hier mit einem
großaufgebot vor ort schwer bewaffnete
elitepolizisten die durchkämmen jetzt
hier noch das gebäude es wird akribisch
wirklich jeder winkel durchsucht weil
man eben nicht ausschließen kann dass es
hier möglicherweise komplizen gegeben
hat stand jetzt geht die polizei
allerdings davon aus dass es sich um
einen einzeltäter handelt über den
übrigens bisher noch nichts bekannt ist
also du kannst du es wäre natürlich
meine frage gewesen sebastian aktuell
noch nicht sagen über hintergrund über
mögliche motivation die tat ist noch
ganz frisch
richtig genau darauf warten wir jetzt
noch die staatsanwaltschaft hat hier den
deckel drauf sagt man so schön und so
lange dringen hier über die polizei
leider keine informationen nach außen
danke sebastian bringen unser bild
reporter in hamm in nordrhein westfalen
nach dieser neuen bluttat dort an der
hochschule mindestens vier menschen dort
verletzt nach einer messerattacke danke
für die ersten information